you see yeah I haven't seen one yet I
love this was the right shirt for this
interview
[Laughter]
we got a lint roller what's your
favorite body part your own hands yeah
yeah no I don't like let me see those
hands
it's a good body part Thanks do you have
a go-to artist or classic Otis Redding
well yeah some Sam Cooke on the same
same vibe any manscaping tips actually
which is a put your body lotion in the
shower
go on yeah so you put your body lotion
the shower and then you towel off in
there and then when it's all steamy in
there and then you hydrate your skin
does it get it doesn't get like too wet
still it doesn't have to tell off from
there you get nice and dry
got it what was tea mr. president uh-huh
what's the best vacation you've been on
my favorite place in the world is Big
Sur really why go we try to go once a
year for my birthday because for my
first birthday when Allison and I were
together she threw me a surprise party
which was no it was the first time I've
ever had an anxiety attack really it's
kind of mid party when I decided to have
one of the the special brownies and
things weren't going good as is
[Laughter]
he's got a long torso
yeah so it's doubled yeah yeah
technically 16 that's true that's true
[Music]
what's it like working with other
projects I loved it it was it was a
little nerve-wracking at first because
we were in a relationship in the movie
too and you hope there's chemistry
on-screen because otherwise everyone
watching you would be like why are you
exactly
oh but ultimately it's easier than
working with anyone just cuz I can't be
fake in front of her you know anytime
there's like a false moment it's just
exactly exactly do you wish that there
was an additional season of the
leftovers or anything you wish was added
into the show that was cut no I don't
wish for another season and I don't it's
nice to be on a show that just kind of
goes out on top though right and like
leaves people wanting more hope so yeah
I like endings in high school booth um I
was a lot more shy it took me to like
senior year to really come out of my
shell and uh we were the group in high
school who was throwing the frisbee at
lunch we were cool like that
[Music]
were you like in high school I was very
very late so it was early high school
anything middle high school was kind of
a bummer because about a couple heights
shorter still have a high squeaky voice
and didn't have facial hair and all the
things that make you cool in high school
when did that boy scrap I think I want
to say like end of sophomore year - if
you had the chance to join a cast of a
Broadway who you've done a lot of here
you've got a lot of you yeah a Broadway
show
I mean exactly I'm the same way I can't
sing I mean my favorite show ever is
Book of Mormon so if I could sing that
would be the one yeah yeah what's the
biggest risk you've taken that you feel
has paid off my two did skydiving and it
paid off just as far as the straight-up
risks the scariest parts going up yeah
the scariest part I think is sitting on
the edge of the plane and going why am i
jumping out of a perfectly good point
there's that moment - last question
what's the craziest rumor you've heard
about yourself did I sleep naked on
airplanes yeah yeah
some do you know how that originated
she's cracking up over here it's a true
story
[Music]
I think if you could get away with that
[Music]
[Laughter]
by the way we should point out that
these cats are all up for adoption yes
or animal League of America so if you
like one of these sets you can call and
get them either one of these or one just
like it so I usually like sleepy right
they're usually kind of